if we put in the people strategy for you
and give you the actual infrastructure
like put in your ATS system you know put
in your insurances and your payroll and
all your this kind of stuff it allows
them to scale much quicker right but for
us it also allows us to be really sticky
with them because they're obviously then
going to give us all their search right
so it just kind of works that way and
then from from a business perspective
it's reoccurring Revenue when you're
sitting across from private Equity they
want to hear a narrative they want to
hear a story you know just like you ask
me what's what's your point of
difference right and then you say okay
who offers them well in cleanergy no one
probably at the in the US then all of a
sudden you've got a compelling story
right whilst also having it's it's solid
business it's good business